the Intel i7 87k is a solid CPU but with
there being other offerings from AMD and
the 9000 series being just from the
corner it doesn't really make sense to
buy anymore
[Music]
welcome to Horus hobbies so if you guys
didn't already know the Intel i7 87k is
a hexaco cluster with six cores and
twelve threads with the base frequency
at 3.7 a Hertz and IMAX turbo frequency
of four point seven years and it comes
in at three hundred and six dollars and
currently this is the best gaming CPU
available on the mainstream market even
though that sounds really good
it's really not that great because it is
just another 40 nanometer CPU from Intel
which Intel has been giving us since
so this CPU is just more of a
progressive upgrade over last generation
and not really a game changer and Plus
currently we have really good options
from AMD
for example the 2700 X is an octa-core
processor with 8 cores and 16 threads
with the base frequency of 3.7 years and
max trouble frequency of 4.3 Giger's and
only cost 330 dollars on top of that it
is so much better than Intel CPU in
terms of productivity and not far behind
in terms of gaming not to mention it
comes with a great stock cooler while
the Intel variant doesn't even come with
the cooler plus the motherboard that you
would buy for the 27 rx can last you
many generations and you don't have to
buy the top and motherboard to overclock
either to make matters even worse for
the 87 arcade the 9000 series is just
around the corner and guess what it's
another 40 nanometers series and the 10
anime series is delayed even further
from the beginning of 2019 - all the way
to the fall of 2019
at first we expected that Intel would be
launching an i7 97 RK which should have
eight cores and 16 threads and via
add-on to the coffee-like series which
would be compatible with the z3 98
platform and so at that point the $0.80
werner k would still have its place but
instead into us actually planning on
introducing a full new series with the
9000 series and they're going to be
bringing the
9 series on to mainstream platform with
the I'm 999 hundred K which is going to
be the octa-core processor that we were
expecting and the nineties of RK is just
actually going to be another hexa-core
processor just like the 87 or ek well
how does the 97 Rek perform you ask well
it will most likely be identical to 8086
k with 6 cores and 12 threads with the
base frequency of 4 gigahertz and a max
trouble frequency of 5 years and if you
guys don't remember the 8086 k was
already just a bin version of the 87
decay so 9 7 r K is really just a
booster version of the 87 arcade once
the 97 arcade comes out if the 87 Recces
dropped in price it would actually still
make a lot of sense by the 87 or decay
however based on past intelligence that
doesn't seem to be the case because even
right now the 77 re k cost three hundred
and forty dollars and only dropped $20
over MSRP so based on that the 87 RK and
97 K will only be separated by $20 so
once the 97 or EK comes out it would
really make no sense to go into 87 or k
anymore they still get more performance
with a 97 or DK for not that much more
really so really it doesn't make sense
to buy the 80s have murmured k anymore
because the 97 RK is coming really soon
and it is going to be this exact same
chip with higher clocks for the same
price on top of this there are really
big things expected with AMD's 3000
series of Rison it is expected that it
will be on the seventh animated process
and they will overclock all the way to
five years and it may even have 12 or 16
cores I don't think it'll have that many
cores but what I think will happen is
that AMD will reintroduce to 800 series
so 230 737 RX will have 8 cores and 16
threads just like usual and the 3,800 ex
may have 10 or 12 cores and the 3000
series will most definitely offer a
better value than their Intel
counterparts and they will be perfect
for extreme performance and if you want
even better performance of that then
your best bet would be to I $9.99
hundred K which I'll have eight cars in
16 threads and it's maxed turbo
frequency will most likely be higher
4.32 years because that is the max turbo
frequency of the 27 Rex and I bet the
intel wants to offer a higher max turbo
frequency at AMD does and considering
how good Intel CPUs at overclocking we
will most likely see a max turbo
frequency of four point five to four
point seven years officially and we may
even be able to overclock into the high
fours or even five gigahertz with the
9900 K now this CPU will be expensive at
450 to 500 dollars but it will be
compatible with even the 8 series of
platform motherboards is what the rumors
suggest so that should save you money
wait if you're buying the CPU I don't
recommend you buy an H series for
beetrice motherboard but it needs to be
70 motherboard would be a great option
for these new CPU
so overall the 87 or K just really
doesn't make sense right now because
it's just in the middle of nowhere
really if you want the best value out
there then the Rison series is
definitely the way to go with the 2700 X
or 2700 and if you want extreme
performance than the 9900 K or the
upcoming 3800 access where you want to
be going and even if the 87 RK is
exactly the chip you want the 97 RK is
coming up really soon and it is going to
one-up it for the exact same price so
there is a better CPU out there for all
of you guys so I really don't recommend
that any of you guys buy the 80s at
menarche right now unless there is an
extreme deal on it like $300 so what do
you guys think about this what do you
think about AMD moving on a7 animator
process while until it's still stuck
with the 40 nanometer process make sure
to comment down below what you guys
think because I do we all like comments
and cues as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like this view then make sure
to drop a like and consider subscribing
if you'd like to see more videos just
like this one but until next time I'm
Hari I'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]